I had what a lot of people would be
considered a good life as living the
proverbial American Dream you know I
quit my job to start my own business
made an okay living had great clients
did good work and yet I'd lost my
passion for that and didn't want to wake
up and go to go to work anymore which
was embarrassing because superficially
everything was just fine I was
pretending that I was happier more in
control and more successful than I was
or felt um which is quite frankly pretty
draining and pretty dark and it wasn't
until a very very close friend of mine
came to me and said something's wrong
she was the first one to notice
something and I came clean and I sort of
let it all out it was that catharsis
that sort of lifted this heavy weight
off my shoulders I was no longer alone
it was no longer a secret um and all of
the energy that was previously going
into lying hiding and faking now went
into finding a solution